we're pretty much over i loved him from
the bottom of my heart i always have
and i will continue to no matter what
she needs
david adefaso is addressing his
high-profile split from tamar braxton
and his request for a restraining order
i will not speak out
speak out ill against somebody i love
so much i've always loved david started
his youtube live on wednesday by
addressing the issue of mental health in
america
first of all i'd like to say that mental
health is real
it's really real we should be able to
talk about it openly
and not consider it to be a stigma it is
not a stigma one thing we can't forget
however
is the impact on the family
um it's hard but
uh it's important that we continue to
stand by and support people who have
mental health in august tamar credited
david with saving her life in an
emotional
instagram post after he found her
unresponsive in july at the ritz-carlton
residences in downtown l.a
where they were staying and what's
emergency
my girlfriend is not responding are you
with her right now
yes the 43 year old singer was rushed to
the hospital and was later transferred
to another hospital facility in l.a
to receive more specialized mental
health treatment from top
specialists fast forward to tuesday and
david filed for a domestic violence
restraining order against tamar
and in his youtube live he confirmed
their relationship
is over i love tamar with my entire
heart
i loved her from day one
with my entire heart my heart my body my
soul my spirit
i loved her with everything i had and i
stood by her
through thick and thin i went to bed for
my girl
as a man should no matter what and i'll
continue to do it today
um i'll continue to stand by team on no
matter what
the 49 year old businessman then alleged
that he was a victim of domestic abuse
and claimed that tamar assaulted him i
will never
never bring myself to attack tamar
somebody i've spent so long with i
never will it's just not something i
will do i'll speak the truth
and here's the truth i've been a victim
of domestic violence domestic assault
i i was attacked
david claims he was driving at a high
speed when he was unexpectedly hit
in the neck by tamar leaving him
disoriented
scared and confused david says that
after the alleged attack he was being
secretly recorded
and claims tamar taped his reaction to
being hit
and sent it to his family and friends in
addition to all that
he says the incident in question led him
to crashing his rolls-royce
causing 30 thousand dollars in damages
and david says the altercation was his
basis for requesting a restraining order
he further addresses and denies
accusations of physically abusing tamar
which he says have been leveled against
him by unnamed parties e.t has reached
out to tamar for comment
i have never ever ever
i never will ever put my hand on a woman
ever i grew up in a household uh
my parents were together for 50 years
and my mom and dad
were the most loving and kind couple to
each other
i didn't grow up in that environment i
never ever
laid a hand on tama braxton
or any woman in my entire life
but we haven't heard tamar's side and a
source is telling the blast that the
domestic violence
actually went the other way the source
says it was david who caused the car
accident
he has yet to respond to the site's
report after taymar's hospitalization
david spoke out publicly about her
condition explaining that she had been
struggling with depression
quote please continue to send prayers
and hope as tamar continues the path to
recovery
and ultimate happiness